[Music]
my name is Juan Pérez I live here in Salada we
live off fishing we are a
fishing community
[Music]
no good It's been 4 years
since we met the lion fish and it's been the
lion fish in the sea I think it's a
kind of  that is exterminating what
the fish is, the lobster, because it
eats the egg, we say, that's
why we are trying to
exterminate them [Music] I have a husband who is a
fisherman
because it is difficult for us because
we only depend on that and
right now the  Lionfish is eating
everything
[Music]
and and I like it because that is not a schedule
that you have to have, you do it in your
free time that you have like I have a
son I have for him all day so at
night I get on and
do it  I have four children and it is difficult
for me to support myself from that. So
I liked the idea and I said, well, I'm going to
help myself, I'm going to help my family and
that's how I'm going to help my husband. My
husband is a fisherman and he brings me the
altitas.  me free for me it's not that
difficult to get them and I like I like
[Music]
do it as
bishy
misconception Lion Fish fishing so One
of the First barriers we Had to overcome
Of course was this huge fear of people
Getting stung everybody's afraid of
Getting stung by  a Lion
[Music]
Fish we Had Hold events in the middle of
the Town I show people How to remove the
spines Show them How to clean it Just
like any other regular Fish and invited
people to eat
So I come a distance
like from here  Let's say this is
the head of the This is the tail we
dedicate ourselves to looking for them to nail them
to
sell the
lobster harvest So we
dedicate ourselves to fishing the Li Fish as I
told you at the beginning we have a business now
we have a
market right now we have 3  For years of
serving lionfish, people
like it a lot. There is a fisherman who brings me 15 or
20 pounds. So how much can I
buy from them? I buy from them because I know it
is a good profit for me and
tourism likes it too much. But it is the
popular dish. At first we thought.  that you
couldn't work you couldn't eat but
I think that now it is a
[Music]
benefit that inv in80 theid ofish
North of mi